news now to buy a new car or keep your
old one a big question manny are we
thinking lately jeremy j ford went to an
auto repair shop to show you why your
vehicle might be worth keeping
it's cars like this old bmw that are now
on the road longer because people are
choosing to get those cars fixed due to
today's economy this will be my last
investment for a car ross raimondo owns
a 10 year old toyota tacoma and wants to
convert it to a van for his grandkids
but doesn't want to buy a new car
comparing the price that i got here is
almost double
double the price of a new tacoma he like
mark oliver believes it's cheaper to
keep her no car notes
this one's just about paid off so
i'll be owning it really soon so i plan
on keeping it for a long time and that's
what other drivers are doing as well due
to supply chain shortages higher gas
prices and the cost of a new car i think
it's more of a comfort thing
says body shop owner aaron scrock who
fixes cars daily we have seen a
higher value giving for used vehicles
with the
chip shortage and
just really everything the inventory
everything is just tightened up leading
more car owners to take better care of
their wheels just invest in your own car
just fix it you're going to jump into a
note and you're really not going to be
you know you're not going to like that
jeremy j ford live local now
according to some data released by s p
global mobility the average vehicle on
the road this is hard to believe but
it's 12 years two months old
yes the highest number recorded more
than 20 years since the data has been
tracked